how's it going everybody it's Warren and
tomorrow is going to be a great day for
Marvel fans we're going to be getting
new footage for two Marvel movies one in
the MCU and one in Sony spider-verse
now for the Black Widow fans out there
great news we are getting a black widow
exclusive tomorrow this is going to be
brand new footage not shown in the
original trailer but widely believed to
be the footage that was shown at Cece X
be the Comic Con experience in South
Paulo Brazil not too long ago now I've
been hearing a lot of people say that
this could be the official trailer for
Black Widow at first we got the teaser
trailer and now we are getting the
official trailer but however this is
most likely not true we just got the
official teaser trailer for Black Widow
in December last month and some more
time is probably going to have to go by
until we get the official trailer and
Marvel is known to do special exclusive
looks of their films so that is most
likely what is going to happen said to
be during the Oscar nominations and then
we have a confirmation of the Morbius
trailer it is in fact coming tomorrow
morning there have been rumors that the
trailer could hit tomorrow morning and
now it is confirmed as Tyrese Gibson
took to his Instagram and confirmed this
himself he posted on Instagram tomorrow
morning hashtag flamethrower the
excitement is real around our Morbius
trailer dropping tomorrow morning 13
2020 and something very very interesting
that he put down below he put hashtag
MCU is Morbius going to take place in
the MCU well it's certainly looking that
way as we have confirmation that they
are going to reference spider-man and
the events from spider-man far from home
in Morbius this is extremely exciting
news and can open up the future of the
MCU to so many different possibilities
including venom spider-man carnage
Kraven the hunter Morbius Morbius and
Blade morbius and blade and Moon Knight
the possibilities are endless so it's
definitely an exciting time tomorrow we
get the first trailer for Morbius and an
exclusive look at Black Widow with new
footage let me know who's psyched about
this and let me know who would like
Morbius to be a part of the MCU drop
your comments below also leave a like
and don't forget to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and the Sony spider-man verse and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 as always
thank you all so much for watching well
whoof